how does the nervous system work the
nervous system works with a lot of magic
from the universe
do i get another phd after i finish this
hi i'm mayam bialik and i'm here with
wired to answer
the 50 most googled questions about
neuroscience
[Music]
is neuroscience a biological science
i'm gonna say yes it's about
biological systems yes what nervous
system controls breathing
autonomic nervous system is in charge of
breathing structures
what nervous system controls heart rate
that would be sympathetic
parasympathetic
yes how does the autonomic nervous
system affect the heart rate
by making it go up or making it go down
how do hallucinogens affect the central
nervous system
wow hallucinogens affect the central
nervous system by
changing the distribution of
neurotransmitter and specifically
crossing modalities uh creating
synesthetic experiences where auditory
and visual
information effectively gets crossed
what neurotransmitters are involved in
schizophrenia
um schizophrenia is is a varied disorder
that can involve
paranoia and delusions um and
depersonalization
dopamine serotonin and obviously all of
the other neurotransmitters but
specifically those
um for schizophrenia what is
neurotransmitter testing
neurotransmitter testing is testing i
guess amounts
of dopamine and serotonin uh which are
typically done from
um swabs but i guess you can do it from
blood maybe super spinal fluid yeah
which neurotransmitter acts to
facilitate learning
that's a really difficult question to
answer i mean all of your
neurotransmitters contribute to
everything about you
the way that we learn is really because
of a lot of things it's because of
attention it's because of mood it's
because of
reward activation mine's a more
philosophical answer but
i don't know the structure of the brain
that they're talking about which is
probably
regulated so which neurotransmitter is
associated with parkinson's disease uh
parkinson's disease is a basal ganglia
disease that would be dopamine as the
primary neurotransmitter
how information travels in the nervous
system all sorts of crazy ways
up down sideways inside out information
travels from the brain to the spinal
cord and out to the periphery and then
from the periphery back
into the spinal cord and back up to the
brain how does a stroke affect the
nervous system
well it depends where the stroke is um
there's specific kinds of regions of the
brain where a stroke will
lead to paralysis or the inability to
speak certain strokes will affect very
interesting things they'll make you
think that
you don't understand people's faces
there's so many different things it can
affect
having the blood supply cut off will
impair a region of the brain is the most
basic definition of a stroke though
what is neuroscience perspective a
neuroscience
perspective is seeing the world as a
series of
motivations and thoughts and feelings
that impact
biological processes and affect how we
interact with the world
how many neurons are in the nervous
system i don't remember
a lot what neurotransmitter controls the
somatic nervous system
the somatic nervous system is is the
nervous system
associated with sensory information uh
for me that's
gonna kind of be um many all of them
i mean impulses are always regulated by
by gabin by glutamate and um
acetylcholine is one of them
are eyes part of the nervous system i
love this question
yes the retina and the optic nerve are
part of the nervous system
what are excitatory neurotransmitters
excitatory neurotransmitters are
transmitters that have a plus sign as it
were
they they lead to an increase in
secretion or an
increase in activity what sends
neurotransmitters toward the next neuron
oh i could talk about this for days um
neurotransmitters are are packaged in
vesicles
and they move along microtubule
filaments along the axon
what are neurotransmitters and how do
they function holy toledo
neurotransmitters are
chemicals that are produced in the brain
and the body that act on
other parts of the brain and body they
are the main communication
module for the the nervous system
they function by binding to receptors
and the binding onto receptors opens up
different channels and activity
that then leads to other
neurotransmitter being released
how are hormones different from
neurotransmitters hormones are typically
generated outside of the nervous system
as it were there are neuro hormones
it really depends on what things are
acting on and why and how
um but neurotransmitters typically are
generated in the central nervous system
and hormones can be
generated and modulated outside as well
how does nicotine affect the nervous
system
nicotine affects the nervous system in a
lot of excitatory ways
nicotine also does have inhibitory
effects
and can lead to feelings of relaxation
and decrease in agitation
what is a synapse in the nervous system
well
i went to ucla and the cafe that we had
in the neuroscience building was called
cafe
synapse because it's where things come
together
that's right folks a synapse is where
two neurons meet
and release information and that's where
things come together
how does the digestive system work with
the nervous system
pretty darn well for most people
how does the nervous system and
endocrine system work together
well since my field is psycho
neuroendocrinology
i should know a lot about this and
indeed i do
the endocrine system is typically the
hypothalamic pituitary axis
hpa includes the adrenals and um
hormones are released from the pituitary
gland and then flow through the body and
the hypothalamus and then become part of
the nervous system where
um they affect the brain and all sorts
of behavioral and
biological functions they work together
really well
how to keep your nervous system healthy
well this is a wonderful question
get a lot of sleep drink a lot of water
eat as simply as possible
do not drink alcohol at all if you can
avoid it
i would say avoid um as much
pharmaceutical impact in your life as is
possible
and avoid illicit drugs and they're
generally not good for your nervous
system
learn how to breathe properly meditate
and please go to therapy
what neurotransmitter causes migraines
i get migraines and i don't know the
answer to this i think migraines are
caused by stress
that's my unofficial non-doctor opinion
i could list all the people that give me
migraines and none of them
are the names of neurotransmitters is
neuroscience a good major
hell yeah it is you get to learn about
the brain and nervous system
you get to learn about the fact that we
exist we have consciousness
we can communicate we can love we can
hate we can change we can grow
that's why it's not only a good major
it's a good
grounding for life so there
how does caffeine affect the nervous
system caffeine affects the nervous
system by
doing a lot of excitatory things it
increases your heart rate
it will make you go poop and pee because
it's a diuretic
and it does increase alertness and
vigilance
uh which also can lead to a crash
a caffeine crash and it is addictive so
it affects the nervous system by
um getting the nervous system used to
having it as a normal way to function
and it resets your sense of normal so
that's why when you quit caffeine you go
into withdrawal
how the nervous system works with other
systems
the nervous system works with other
systems by being
connected through the series of
peripheral nerves that
that exist meaning all organs send
information to the nervous system
i like to think of the nervous system as
the main system
because it's your brain your spinal cord
and all of the nerves that serve the
rest of your body
so it's kind of the master system how
does the skeletal system work with the
nervous system
certain skeletal systems support
the the most important aspects of the
nervous system so the skull
this thing it's actually the holding
place for
the brain the lobes of the brain and all
the things about the brain
and the entire vertebral system the
vertebrae of your spinal cord are
actually protecting
a very very important uh passage of
information from your brain to the rest
of your body so the skeletal system is
is the scaffold to protect the nervous
system
where are neurotransmitters made
neurotransmitters are made anywhere you
want them to be
brain organs mostly brains in the middle
of the brain
yes all the little parts that's a
terrible answer
are cranial nerves part of the central
nervous system cranial nerves
i think would be considered the
peripheral nervous system
brain spinal cord periphery for the love
of pete
how many neurotransmitters are there
let's say between three and four dozen
is acetylcholine a neurotransmitter yeah
it is
how does diabetes affect the nervous
system because of the
changes in blood glucose levels
this can cause strain on blood vessels
i'm thinking as i'm answering there are
also
cognitive shifts that happen because of
diabetes
what kind of chemical is released at a
synapse
a neurochemical also known as a
neurotransmitter which neurotransmitter
is associated with depression
that would be serotonin dopamine
sometimes is implicated as well
and because everybody's brain is
different um not everyone
has the same kind of depression and if
you have depression that is
part of manic depression you might need
a different kind of treatment or
understanding of your neurotransmitter
system
but classical depression serotonin how
do neurotransmitters influence behavior
by communicating every thought every
movement we have
the the way that you exist is because of
electrical signals caused by
the release of neurotransmitter there is
nothing about you
even love that cannot be explained by
neurotransmitter
how does alcohol affect the nervous
system alcohol is a depressant
um alcohol will first affect the cells
of the cerebellum
those are the ones back here and they
affect the things that you
most frequently see when you do a
sobriety test the ability to do fine
motor control to walk a line
to do this one it affects the general
nervous system
with a lot of psychological and
psychiatric impact that's going to vary
by human and alcohol is a toxin
so your body perceives it as such and
all of the changes that happen when you
have
alcohol are essentially your body
processing so that it can get rid of the
alcohol
how does the nervous system help the
body maintain homeostasis
well the nervous system is what
maintains homeostasis uh through a lot
of different things
the the hypothalamus is is your main
your main friend for this the
hypothalamus maintains body temperature
um urinary levels hunger puberty
circadian rhythms basically regulating
every single organ
system um like homeostasis is the
nervous system that's it's gold
is dopamine a neurotransmitter oh yeah
which neurotransmitter is associated
with sleep mood and appetite
it really depends on what's happening
i'm going to go ahead and go for
serotonin will mess up all of those
what is neuroscience psychology uh
neuroscience psychology or neuropsych as
we call it
um is an emphasis on the underlying
nervous system substrates of
psychological phenomenon
how does cannabis affect the nervous
system how doesn't cannabis affect the
nervous system really should be this
question
cannabis affects the nervous system by
binding to cannabinoid receptors duh
and those receptors do a lot
surrounding relaxation relaxation of
muscles literally
cannabis stimulates appetite if you
think people who use it medicinally for
example for for chemotherapy
um it it can reduce nausea and
it has analgesic effects it has numbing
effects
that's sort of like high feeling that
people report
it's typically an an ability to have a
strong connection with your sensory
systems
and that can make you feel really really
happy
what does multiple sclerosis do to the
nervous system multiple sclerosis
um causes demyelination of axons
myelin is the the fat that that lines
axons which is how
a neuron communicates information from
the cell body to
the dendrites and once that
that myelin that fat is broken down it
makes it much harder for electrical
impulses to travel
so um it makes communication between
cells harder
why nervous system important why is the
nervous system important because
it is the foundation of your existence
as a human both physically and
metaphysically the brain and the nervous
system
your spinal cord and all your nerves are
everything about how you interact with
the world
including what you love what you hate
how you can even process what i'm saying
right now
and your position in space and your
acknowledgment that we are hurtling
through the universe at high speed and
not flying off the planet and we
exist now and will exist tomorrow all
that is your nervous system
is epinephrine a neurotransmitter yes
which systems comprise the nervous
system uh there's the central nervous
system
that's the brain and the spinal cord and
there's the peripheral nervous system
which is the nerves on the periphery
what are nervous system disorders uh
there are a lot of nervous system
disorders
let's see multiple sclerosis alzheimer's
parkinson's
muscular dystrophy epilepsy pretty much
all
of psychiatric challenges you know
depression anxiety
obsessive compulsive disorder
dissociative identity disorder i could
go on
how does the nervous system work the
nervous system works with a lot of magic
from the universe
it does information that's produced in
the brain that's sent down the spinal
cord
to the peripheral nervous system
receives information from the outside
world brings it back in
sends it up the spinal cord then your
brain processes it and you
act and think and feel and exist
what is the nervous system the nervous
system is the series
of cells that comprise the brain
and the spinal cord and allows you to
perceive
your body your feelings and interact
with the outside world
feel and think your nervous system is
you
those were the 50 most googled questions
on neuroscience thank you for watching
hope i did okay